Less than two months from the release of Avengers:
Endgame, we've still had no Hulk sightings.
So where is he?
Until the movie arrives in theaters, there's
no way to know for sure, but for now, here's
a look at some of the most likely reasons
you haven't seen Hulk in the Avengers: Endgame
trailers.
If the body count of Avengers: Endgame is
anything like what we saw in Avengers: Infinity
War, then there's good reason to assume the
Hulk might not survive the latest Avengers
adventure.
In fact, you could argue that he has less
chance of surviving Endgame than most.
We haven't heard a lot about whether Mark
Ruffalo plans to keep playing the character
after this movie, but we're pretty sure Marvel
won't be pursuing any solo Hulk films anytime
soon.
Additionally, Endgame marks the end of the
"Hulk trilogy" that Ruffalo discussed with
MCU boss Kevin Feige that began with Thor:
Ragnarok.
So if there's a time for the Hulk to take
a final bow, now seems pretty appropriate.
If directors Joe and Anthony Russo were to
kill the Hulk, doing it early in the fight
might accomplish the same thing Hulk's beating
at the hands of Thanos did in Infinity War.
Having Thanos defeat the Avengers' toughest
muscleman in the first few minutes of the
film let audiences know what kind of threat
the heroes were facing.
The stakes are likely to be raised in Endgame,
and it may be that the filmmakers decided
the only thing more effective than having
Thanos K.O. the Hulk in the first few minutes
would be to have Thanos take Hulk out permanently.
If that's the case, there might not actually
be much Endgame footage that wouldn't spoil
the hero's death — hence his absence from
the trailers.
But if we're being totally honest?
This doesn't seem too likely compared with
some of the other possible reasons we've come
up with.
While green is the color most often associated
with the Hulk, over the years we've seen that
green and gamma rays don't always go hand
in hand.
The Hulk was gray in his first 1962 comic
book appearance, and in the late '80s that
version of the Hulk made a successful return.
In 2008 — the same year Marvel Studios released
the first two MCU films, Iron Man and Incredible
Hulk — Marvel Comics introduced the world
to the Red Hulk, a more villainous Hulk with
bright red skin.
So while it ain't easy being green, it may
be even harder for the Hulk to stay green.
It's possible that the reason Marvel Studios
has held back footage of the Big Guy from
the Avengers: Endgame trailers is that they
plan to premiere one of these non-green Hulks
in Endgame and don't want to spoil the reveal.
Of course, images snapped of the forthcoming
batch of Endgame action figures have already
revealed of a green-colored Hulk.
So let's put this particular theory down as
similarly unlikely.
In terms of the Hulk's appearance, Disney
was a little mean to us when they released
the Avengers: Infinity War trailers.
Shots in the trailer clearly showed the Hulk
alongside Captain America, Bucky, the Falcon,
and other heroes charging Thanos' army in
the Battle of Wakanda.
That, of course, never actually happened.
Sure, Bruce Banner got to take a pretty awesome
joyride in the Hulkbuster armor, but there
wasn't much genuine Hulk-smashing in Avengers:
Infinity War.
It may be that the Hulk isn't in the Endgame
trailers because the Russos may be trying
to manage fan expectations.
Who knows how much Hulk we'll get?
By keeping him out of the trailers, Marvel
Studios may be ensuring that this question
remains as unanswered as possible, so that
if he shows up at all, we'll all stand up
and cheer our faces off.
Sort of like this:
“YESSS!"
One of the most beloved moments of 2012's
Avengers film was this classic line from Bruce
Banner:
"I'm always angry.”
It was a huge, crowd-pleasing moment and it
officially brought the team together after
two hours of bickering.
While the green guy hadn't been in the movie
much before that moment, after that classic
line, he stole the show.
There was this moment:
“And Hulk?
Smash."
And this moment:
And of course, the best moment of quite possibly
any movie ever made:
“I am a god, you dull creature!
And I will not be bullied by—"
And part of what made all these moments so
successful was the relative lack of Hulk in
the rest of the movie.
Chances are good the Russos are building up
to a new version of the "I'm always angry"
line.
Maybe they plan to redeem the Hulk's absence
and thrashing in Infinity War by giving the
green guy the same kind of memorable moment
he enjoyed in Avengers.
In the meantime, maybe they're hoping the
Hulk's absence from the marketing will make
our hearts grow fonder — and our cheers
that much louder.
"Hulk!
Hulk!
Hulk"
Of course, there's one more possible reason
we may not have seen the Hulk...and it's all
the Fresh Prince's fault.
Not too long ago, Disney released footage
of Will Smith as Aladdin's blue-skinned genie.
“You really don't know who I am… genie,
wishes, none of that ringing a bell?"
The online responses were...less than ideal.
So could Marvel Studios, a subsidiary of Disney,
be holding the big green Hulk back because
they're still feeling burned after going blue?
"I feel like a f---ing idiot."
Could Marvel really, truly be worried about
their special effects in the biggest movie
they've ever released suddenly not looking
up to snuff?
"I'm kidding.
Watch this."
Nah.
If there's one thing we know for sure by now,
it's that Marvel Studios knows exactly when
to Hulk out, and how keeping the Hulk hidden
can actually make the biggest impact.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.